[Music]
voodoo
so passupuru
this search y 9 minutes big I will be
the factory manager of protection who is in charge of video and management
Display should be burberry for time as big as
Audi fick Pooh Pooh Amoeber Hair
Machine in the store  It will be a toy-like thing,
so I think it's impossible in the parliament because it's handmade or something like that can be real-in, so
my name is Takahiro Ishigami.
I think I've been working for about 36 years.
After all, there are tens of thousands of kinds of that food, so it
's in the history of Gar years.
It's about yen, but it's big.
For example, if you become a member or a big one, the price will be 50,000 yen and 100,000 yen
.
Thank you do I think that you can't make good music without at least 23 years of training.
It's all about Ofu ramen matter to me we are ready to do, but when I look at the colorless lati things, I think it's quite
how the tilute was made, so after all it's the charm of such things,
how to make it closer to the real thing.  I'm thinking about various things
[Music]
After all, to make a real heart, I also say real materials, but I
think you can understand that by seeing what you are making
[Music]
wh
ni
I  My name is Hiroshi Sasaki.
I entered this road from 18
[Music]
So I've been specializing in only the style for about 45 years
now.
It takes at least 10 years to make a real taste
.  I think it's
also good to rub my female sister. Because
there is a house without having to touch my hands, I don't want
to be a colorless and transparent god who is mixed with me.
It's called bouvet.
There was a bra  In the
case of bonito flakes, if you use a bonito that is a comprehensive art and has a wonderful vessel
,
you can make a theta that stands out.
You can see that by seeing it made.
[Music]
me
today
This is bonito flakes. It's made from that activity.
Moonless is said to be the hardest food in the world.  It
gets harder like this
ani
I'm Suzukita Takashi, but I'm making crushed
bonito I've been making bonito for 30 years.
Isn't it? It's
shaving the crushed bonito. Well, this is called
bonito flakes. In the old days, it was
often
used as a so-called topping that is eaten as it is on rice.
It is used and then put in miso. It
is often used for soba and udon.
Katsuobushi is produced in Kagoshima prefecture, Shizuoka prefecture, which is about 90% or more, but
it is crushed anywhere in the country.
This factory is called Yamashi Co., Ltd.
This factory produces about 70 to 75 tons of bonito a
month, and processes about 900 raw materials a year
to make one bonito flakes.  It's been a
long, half-year-old kick
, and then
[music]
It's dried by applying heat
. After drying, the bonito fungus is
activated and sprayed, and it's lit for about 4 months or so.  I think that the
bonito star
craftsmen are getting older, because they are
mechanized, so to be honest, we are in an era where we don't need writers or bonito flakes
.  Because it's a thing, the number of people who cut raw bonito in that way like us is steadily
decreasing.
I feel like we are responsible for the basis of the Japanese food tradition
. Well, do your best.  I'm very wondering if I'm going to continue
[Music]
wh
me
7 minutes
Yes, I want to go, so please give me
Ariya
[Music]
Mitsuo Nakatani Nakatani-do
Co., Ltd. 23 years  Please
me
Raikore
It's also a traditional culture.
Well, when you're happy, mochi is really sticky, isn't it
? Delicious mochi is soft and
stretches well
.  I have glutinous rice to make it.
Well, it arrives firmly and quickly in Japan. You can make mochi with this. It's
not in front of Carkami Tamamorah, but in
some areas, it's
quick to make mochi.  That's
why there is no practice in the practice of Booby Moon. Well,
it was said that I was sick three times because of my illness
.
After
all, I'll do that while calling
out to you. It's a small thing. It's a
true ball game
, so it's a pursuit. That's right. Anyone can do it.
Anyone can do it if
they have the motivation.  I think
that the hurdle is raised too much with yeah, so
I think that the face when eating delicious food has a unique human face, but you can aim for other things
This is the happiest
[Music]
[Applause]
4 add the jerry asos
Angelie Hmmmmmmmm 200 Jerry
pou dou dou follow Faceless Margay Way
It's 4 by capture,
it's bye-by-sea, it's a
triple-
triple pass.  That's
why ran rearea osteria pou dou dou
[music]
voodoo
perks mall ber so far power spin story goes
name
frank Frank
super show powder camp oder ways to
ji  Ellie as to do
5 e 4 f can do today
meet you work undefeated lamp
pb 3 blue soybean winker 2
uh with
ass want porter &
5 against flat ground by immediate action ty government
masanori
[music]
ame
well
pane